[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER: Scott Berkun
is a bestselling author
and popular speaker on
creativity, culture,
and technology.
He's written seven books.
A couple of them
are bestsellers,
like "The Year Without Pants,"
"The Myths of Innovation,"
and "Confessions of
a Public Speaker."
He's been featured in some
popular magazines and stuff,
like "The Wall Street Journal,"
"The Economist," and "Forbes."
And he's the emcee and
speaker for Seattle Ignite.
And so without further ado,
let's give a warm round
of applause for Scott.
[APPLAUSE]
SCOTT BERKUN: Thanks, man.
In 1884, two young
entrepreneurs,
engineers by trade, decided to
pitch and propose a project--
a technological project--
that would change the world.
Now, in 1884, given
how far back in history
that is, the hot
technology of the day,
we're not cloud computing or
mobile web application design.
If you were a young person who
was ambitious, that had skills,
were interested in
engineering and using
technology to make
the human condition
better, the field
you would be working
in would be construction.
Now, for us, we think of
construction as really boring.
It's people with
hardhats and backhoes.
But in 1884, this is the
rise of the industrial age.
This is the rise of railroads
and telegraphy and telephones.
It was also the rise
of industrialization
for construction.
At the time, in 1884, most
buildings in the world
were not more than
a few stories high--
five or six stories high--
because the technology
at the time, the tools at
the time, the materials,
were stone.
And stone is not
reliable at scale.
Generally speaking, it's
not affordable scale
beyond a certain height.
So these two young men in Paris,
France, Koechlin and Nouguier,
they came up with a proposal for
how to use iron, wrought iron--
which was a relatively
new tool and technology
for the age-- to construct
what would be the largest
building in the world.
Now, as all of us would do if
we were in a similar situation,
we had similar ambition, we had
an idea, we had a skill set,
we would put together
a plan or proposal.
We'd want to pitch
people on that idea.
So that's what they did.
And this is what their
pitch looked like.
They drew, on paper, the
design for this building.
And for those of you who have
ever been to Paris or France,
this looks kind
of familiar, now.
One thing they did in
this pitch-- and this
is my first bit of
advice for you--
is the grander the idea
is that you are pitching,
the scarier it is for
people you are pitching to.
You're asking them to
think in a bigger scale
or take a larger amount of risk.
So the first bit of advice I
can give you from my first story
here is that whenever you're
pitching something grand,
you need to find a way to
tell a story about it that
ties it back to things
people already know.
So in this little diagram
here, on the margins,
they were smart
enough to put to scale
six or seven of the
other tallest buildings
in the world that are
already being constructed.
So in the bottom, or
in the right corner,
that's Notre-Dame.
On top of it's the Statue of
Liberty, and on and on it goes.
It so happens that one of
the good fortunes these two
young men had is
they were employed,
they worked for a
man named Eiffel.
Eiffel, one of the
other contributions
he had made before
the Eiffel Tower
was working on the
Statue of Liberty.
So I think they were
trying to say in here, hey,
you could build something
seven times grander
than this other thing
that you worked on.
And it was much some highlight
in the quality of their pitch.
The bad news is that
this pitch failed.
Eiffel was like, eh, it's
tall, but it doesn't really
do anything.
It's kind of like
stunt technology.
It's the tallest or the
fastest, but so what?
It doesn't solve a problem.
And also, from
Eiffel's point of view,
it's not even really that
interesting to look at.
So they rejected the pitch.
But Eiffel, to his
credit, didn't tell them
to stop working on the idea.
He was like, you guys are
passion-- and by the way,
I'm paraphrasing here.
This is not literally
what Eiffel said.
He's like, hey, guys,
I'm not into it.
But you guys are passionate
about it, so keep working.
And they did.
They took his feedback to heart.
They realized they needed
another element to the design
to make it reach
Eiffel's standards.
So they got a third architect
involved, a third engineer,
named Sauvestre.
If you think of the final
design of the Eiffel Tower,
the bottom has those
beautiful arches.
Sauvestre contributed
that design idea.
So all the latticework,
and the fine
patterns, and what looks
like an application
of the golden ratio,
had the shapes
of all these little
windows and this nice feel
to them that draws
your eye in and makes
you want to keep looking at it.
That was Sauvestre's
contribution.
They put together a
new pitch and proposal
and they brought
that back to Eiffel.
And of course, we all know,
this story has a happy ending.
Yay, the Eiffel Tower exists.
And it's probably the most
popular building in the world
that people pay to go see.
Certainly one of the most
popular buildings in history.
And I tell you the story--
I know where I am.
I know I'm at Google.
I know I'm talking
about technology
that's more than 100 years old.
But I'm here because
of a mission--
one of my missions--
which is that we discount
the value of history and what
we can apply from lessons
from history, things that
happened in the past,
to situations and problems
we're trying to solve today.
And this book that
I just wrote called
"The Dance of the
Possible," one of the things
about it is a lot
of the stories I
tell about how to solve
modern problems with working
with ideas come from the past.
Now, history is often
maligned in the tech sector.
But part of what we know about
how all of our brains work
is that whenever you
are making a decision
or you're doing anything
actively today, in the present,
in your life, guess what
is driving your thinking?
History.
Your history from last week,
your history from the meeting
you had yesterday,
your history from what
you learned in school.
All of our decision
making is based
on history, or our ability
to pull lessons out from what
we've already experienced.
So with that in mind, my first
lesson for you from the book
is that all ideas are
made from other ideas.
That all ideas, every idea,
every concept, every product,
every methodology,
every philosophy,
is comprised of other ideas
that came from somewhere else.
So I'm going to ask you to
indulge me for a moment.
I want you all to say this
sentence with me when I say so.
OK, are you going
to do it for me?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
SCOTT BERKUN: I think so.
Good.
OK.
So on the count of three.
One, two, three.
AUDIENCE: All ideas are
made of other ideas.
SCOTT BERKUN: Very good.
Sound like a little
cult. This is good.
We're forming a little
idea cult. Fantastic.
Now, in the abstract, of
course, intellectually,
we all know, yeah, of course.
All ideas are made
from other ideas.
Every mathematical formula
comes from other formulas.
Every bit of
scientific progress is
based on things that
were sorted out before.
That's not really
what I mean here.
What I mean here,
and the application
of this that makes
it useful, is that we
come across ideas, or
products, or notions
that we have so
much respect for,
that we forget this about them.
And the Eiffel Tower's
an interesting example.
How many of you have ever
seen before, that sketch?
The original sketch
of the tower?
No one.
This is one of the most
significant buildings
in the history of the world,
most popular buildings.
But somehow, we
just forget that it
had a back story and a history.
That someone had to pitch
it and it got rejected.
And they had the fortitude
and the grit to keep going.
They had to incorporate and
collaborate with other people,
that all of the stuff
contributed to this thing
that we take for granted today.
So the lesson here,
or the advice is,
whenever you are stuck,
you're working on a problem--
and it could be a
mathematical problem,
it could be an
engineering problem--
and you are stuck,
it probably means
you're forgetting this lesson.
Because when you're stuck, you
don't see any other way to go.
But if you stop and
say, wait a second.
I'm stuck on this problem.
All ideas are made
from other ideas.
What is this thing I am
working on comprised of?
What are the component parts?
Let me step back and go, OK,
has this algorithm, this thing,
this bit of UI, OK.
I'm going to take it apart.
Now I have these six pieces.
Well, what happens if I order
them in a different way.
Or I take two of them and
I add some new thing to it.
Now, all of a sudden,
you're not stuck anymore.
Now, by combining
things, you're not
guaranteed to have a good idea.
But you will be back in
the state of progress
where you are still
exploring and experimenting
to learn more about the problem
that you were trying to solve.
Now, before I
continue this lesson,
my name is Scott Berkun.
Nothing I am sharing with you
up here today is confidential.
I am not a Google employee.
So you are free to take
pictures, post on Twitter--
that's my Twitter handle--
all of my books and
anything else about me,
including my email
address should
you have a question that
we didn't have time for--
Q&A today-- just go
to scottberkun.com
and everything is
there, including
free chapters from the book.
That said, let's get
back to all ideas being
made of other ideas.
So what you see here--
so Eiffel's only known, really,
in most of the Western world
for one product, for one thing.
The tower, the Eiffel Tower.
This is one of the first
buildings that Eiffel worked
on, one of his first projects.
And by comparison, it
is not so exciting.
It's just a square box girder
bridge, and it's workman like,
it functions, I
mean, it's reliable.
It was built to have
trains go across it,
which again, this was a
new technology of the day.
A lot of people were
very scared of trains
so building this really stable
and robust looking building
was probably a good
design criteria.
But there's nothing that
exciting about this building.
This building doesn't
make it into history books
unless you're
someone like me that
wants to go back and find out
well, what did they do before.
But he did incorporate
a whole bunch of ideas
from engineering history.
These grid systems for bridges.
You can see wood bridges that
are made of the same truss
structure, the square
structure repeated over a span.
Later on in his career, this
was maybe five years or so
before the Eiffel
Tower project, now you
can see that his ability
to work with iron--
with wrought iron, which
was the primary medium
he liked to use--
has gotten a lot more detailed.
Some of what Eiffel became--
at least in his
profession was famous for,
was developing techniques
for using wrought iron
more efficiently and
more effectively.
So you look at this
design and it starts
to have some magic to it.
There's some appeal here.
And a particular note to
this theme of all ideas being
made of other ideas.
The central element of
this bridge is an arch.
An arch is one of the
oldest technologies
for engineering construction
we have in the world.
Hundreds and hundreds
of years old.
So he took an old idea here, but
by combining it with something
new he was working with, that
combination-- wrought iron,
which had different properties
for strength and tension, ,
didn't need as much material
to be just as strong--
now it becomes transparent.
You can see through
the arch, which
gives it this dynamic effect.
It's not just a
building anymore.
It's a building that,
when you look at it--
and to some
experience you have--
in your brain, it's just
interesting to look at.
It almost seems like magic.
And you can imagine in
the 1850s and 1860s,
1870s, around the
time this was built,
how magical it must have been
to see this use of an old idea
combine with something new.
We also know that
he had influences,
that Eiffel had thought earlier
on about building a huge tower.
This is the Latting
Observatory, which
was a World's Fair creation in
the 1950s in New York state.
And this building,
when it was built,
was the tallest building.
But Eiffel saw this and had
the same complaint that he had
to his two young engineers
when he saw this.
He said, it's tall
and it's impressive,
but it's basically
built to serve
an abstract,
egotistical function.
It's just the tallest building.
And you could argue,
in a way, that when
he saw this building in the
1850s, many years before he'd
get pitched on the tower
idea, a problem space
was created in his mind.
And building a tall
tower was not enough.
But there could be some
other kind of tall building
that would satisfy
what he thought
was the good use of a
technological innovation.
A more local notion
or example for ideas
being made of other ideas
is this famous drawing
by da Vinci.
Anyone know the name
of this drawing?
AUDIENCE: "Vitruvian Man?"
SCOTT BERKUN: "Vitruvian
Man," very good.
So "Vitruvian Man," that's
the name of this drawing.
And when we hear that,
"Vitruvian Man," we go,
oh, "Vitruvian Man" must be
like the dude in the drawing.
Maybe it was da Vinci's
neighbor, or the model,
it's the name of the
model that he hired.
No.
Vitruvian is a reference
to Vitruvius and Vitruvius
was a Roman architect who lived
a thousand years plus before da
Vinci was even born.
And Vitruvius wrote a book.
That book is called "The
Ten Books on Architecture."
Now, many of you are
engineers or designers
or project managers.
We like to think that art
industry, design patterns,
that we concede to this
notion of putting together
the blueprints for
how these patterns
that repeat in our
work and sharing them.
But Vitruvius wrote
this book called
"The Ten Books on
Architecture," and it's
the first design patterns
book in "The Western Canon."
It's not about software
engineering of course,
but it is about
actual engineering,
actual architecture engineering.
And da Vinci read a
passage in this book that
was about scale proportion.
And this goes back
to the Greeks.
So this Roman guy, as
many of the Romans did,
took ideas from the
Greeks, repurposed them.
Like all the Greek
god names, the Romans
took the same gods, basically,
just put a label on them.
A lot of repurposing went
on in all those traditions.
But specific to
this story, there's
a passage in here that's
purely about the human form.
And it's a passage that talks
about the size of your head
should be about one eighth
of the size of your body,
and the ratio between your
arm length to how long
your legs are.
And da Vinci read this passage
and was inspired enough to say,
I want to make a drawing that
expresses this written idea.
So that's where "Vitruvian
Man" comes from.
But "Vitruvian
Man" is so popular
because da Vinci is so
popular in our culture.
This thing now is
a pattern, an idea,
that's been reused and reused
again and again and again.
Often without any knowledge
of where the idea came from
or what the meaning of it was.
And so now this idea, it's
been reused and recombined
and recombined and recombined.
And you see this
pattern everywhere.
Now, often ideas get reused
in a way that's very ignorant.
It's just this visual
thing that people
go, oh, that's interesting.
I know it's iconic I'm not going
to know why it became iconic,
I'm just going to reuse it.
But then you see
things like this
where the show "Westworld"
has a version of "Vitruvian
Man" in the logo.
And now that you know some
of the history of what
this drawing is from and what
it means, their use of this
is actually very smart.
They're talking about
reinventing man,
reinventing the
idea of proportion,
idea of perfection.
So in these simple notions,
when you start peeling back
the layers of what an idea
is and you want to tear them
apart, the landscape of
possibilities for what
you can do now gets much wider.
Now, to make this more practical
and more about products
and creative thinking for
products, the advice for you
that I have is this.
That if you study the
history of a problem--
the history of the problem.
Not the technology,
but the problem,
you'll find new ideas
for trying to solve it.
The history of the
idea of the problem.
An example that is close to
home, to drive this point home.
Google, the first
major invention,
back when the
company started, was
PageRank, which I'm sure all
of you are very familiar with
and can lecture me about.
But what I know
about PageRank is
that PageRank, the idea that you
can find the value of one page
by examining how well
referenced it is by other pages
and extending that
mathematically
entirely through the network,
is an idea that was not invented
by the founders of Google.
That was an idea that
was, in some sense,
originated from research
papers themselves.
Research papers, academic
papers, footnote at the bottom,
all the people they are
referencing in their paper.
And you can build an
index, and people did this.
There are databases
and academic sources
in colleges that
do the same thing.
They see how many people
reference this paper
and they build an index to find
the most referenced papers.
So the very foundation of
the company that you work for
was the recasting
of an idea that
existed already and applied
to a different medium.
Instead of research
papers, applied to the web.
By understanding the
history of a problem,
you will see different ways of
looking at the problem, which
will invite new ideas and
points of view you would never
find if you didn't go back
and study that history.
Speaking of your competitors,
Amazon is a similar story.
This is an ad from the early
1900s for Sears, Roebuck.
And Sears, Roebuck,
for those of you
who don't know, in the
industrial age, 1890s, 1900,
they were the Amazon of America.
They had a book,
this printed book,
that contained every
product available
that you could possibly
get through mail order.
And mail order itself
was a new idea.
If you read their
little tag line,
it sounds a lot like
Amazon's ads today.
We sell everything
by mail order only.
Your money we promptly return if
you're not perfectly satisfied.
This is basically playbook out
of Amazon's marketing campaign.
And I tell you that
not because I'm
trying to convince you to go
work at Amazon or anything,
but if you compete
with Amazon, this
is another competitive
strategy to use.
Study the history
of the problem.
Some ideas were
successful, but they
were abandoned because the
person who ran with the idea
ran out of money or that
industry, for a time,
took a big hit.
The whole industry did.
So these good ideas are sitting
there for solving a problem
but they're gone.
They've been forgotten.
You go back, have a better
view of the problem,
and those ideas become yours.
From a later catalog
in the 1940s,
this is what basically
the conversion page--
the equivalent of a conversion
web page-- the conversion page
in that catalog looked like.
And if you look at
this catalog design
compared to conversion
pages on the web,
there's a lot of smart
stuff going on here.
You have anchoring,
price anchoring,
using cognitive
science to help figure
out how to convince people
to buy stuff, value leader.
You have zoomed in versions
of the guitar strut.
There's all kinds of ideas here
that you can go back and go,
wait a second.
There's things we've lost
in all of our progress.
We've made things a lot
better in some ways,
but there's ideas
here that could
be reused and experimented
with and re-applied.
My second lesson for you,
and I only have two more
and then we'll open the
floor for questions.
My second lesson for you
is that great ideas often
look weird at first.
If you are dealing
with a notion that
is so much superior to
what you are familiar with,
it's not going to
look normal to you.
It's not going to make sense
in the worldview that you have.
And when you go back and
look at the history of how
we developed all these
technologies that
we now take for granted--
railroads being one,
the internet and the web
being the second, mobile
devices being third.
Go back and read
about the first couple
of years of those devices
being products and people just
looking at them, why
would you use that for?
What would that do for me?
That's the common response
even if the idea is sound.
So to tie this back
home to the first story.
When Eiffel proposed the tower
idea to the Parisian World's
Fair committee, they accepted
it, which we all know.
Two things happened.
One, they told them we accept
it but only at half the budget
you proposed.
Half the budget.
Eiffel was a businessman.
We like to think of it
now as an arts project.
This was purely done for
the beauty of the world.
No, he was a businessman.
So he saw this as
an opportunity.
He's like, fine, I'll put up
the other half of the capital
if I get ticket concessions.
I get to sell
baguettes when people
get inside the Eiffel Tower.
I get all that money.
So it's a business proposition
for him first and foremost.
Second, and this is the
most shocking thing.
Agree on the budget.
They started working.
They broke ground on
building the Eiffel Tower.
300 or more of the leaders
of the cultural Zeitgeist
in Paris, which is the
world leader at the time
of the arts in world--
poets, architects, musicians,
writers, politicians all
got together in
outrage at how much
they hated the idea
of the Eiffel Tower.
They hated it.
They thought it was a rejection
of all the norms of aesthetics.
It was a rejection of the idea
of what technology should do.
300 got together--
300 of these experts
got together and wrote
an essay that they
made into a pamphlet-- it also
published in newspapers-- where
they basically said, we
have to kill this project.
I'm going to read a small
passage of this to you.
"We writers,
painters, sculptors,
architects protest with
all of our strength,
with all our
indignation in the name
of slighted French taste--"
which is a powerful force--
"slighted French taste
against this tower."
They also call it this mass of
iron gymnasium apparatus, which
is pretty insulting.
And all of us look at this and
go, these people were so wrong.
How could they say this
about this great work?
And that's how I
felt about this, too,
when I first heard about this.
But that's where this notion
of good ideas seeming weird
is important, because we have
to put our heads back in time.
We know too much now.
Go back to 1885.
Tallest buildings in
Paris, other than some
of the churches, six stories
high, five stories high.
You're walking around these
great promenades and parks,
you're eating a baguette and
some cheese, having some wine.
You're walking and
strolling along.
And then, you turn a
corner and you see this.
It does look kind of
monstrous in that context.
It does look really foreign.
Iron, wrought iron,
is a new technology.
This is not something
people are used
to, used to seeing
or understanding
or even feeling is safe.
So they saw this and
that was their response.
And from that perspective,
it's entirely understandable.
How can they
conceive of why this
has merit when it's the first
time they've seen something
like it.
A more recent example.
I know that I have forced all of
you to go back in time to ages
when there was no electricity.
So I'm going to give
you an example that's
a little bit more
recent, actually,
in the time of electricity.
I'm going to show you
a picture of a device,
a prototype, a prototype
of a device that's
one of the most important
inventions in the last 50
years, and I want to see if
you can guess what it is.
So I'm going to show it to you.
If you think you know what
it is, just raise your hand.
And again, it's a prototype,
not the final version.
I saw one hand, just
hold on a second.
Two hands.
OK, I'll make it a
little bit easier.
So I pulled a
dirty trick on you.
This picture is upside down.
Does that help at all?
I'm just kidding.
It was right side up before.
No, I'm just screwing
with you, now.
Actually, this is the right way.
This is the right way.
So two people raised their hand.
Do have still the guess?
Anybody?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
but it's too recent.
So this is an electrical box.
SCOTT BERKUN: Electrical box?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
SCOTT BERKUN: Like for
shock therapy or something?
Like what--
AUDIENCE: The thing
you put in a wall.
SCOTT BERKUN: Put in a wall.
OK.
Other guesses?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Is that a doorbell?
SCOTT BERKUN: Doorbell, nope.
So I'll give you a hint.
This object here
is a human knee.
AUDIENCE: A what?
SCOTT BERKUN: A human knee.
Human knee.
Part of your body.
You're knee, middle of your leg.
Prototype.
OK, so I'll cut
to the chase here.
This is a prototype that
was made by Doug Engelbart
and Doug Engelbart is the
inventor of the mouse.
And what he was thinking at
the time-- this is late 1860s--
he's thinking of how do I make
human-computer interaction
better?
How do people interact with
computers and machines in 1865?
Well, there's not
that many devices yet.
There's cars.
Sorry?
AUDIENCE: 18 or 19?
SCOTT BERKUN: 19.
Yeah.
That would be
impressive if he was
working on the mouse in 1865.
So in 1965, how did people
interact with machines?
What's the interaction
models that we have?
Cars.
You drive with your car and
you drive with your hands
you drive with your
feet, foot on the pedal.
So that's one mode
that could be used.
Also, sewing machines, which is
really the primary inspiration
for this.
Sewing machine, you
work with your hands,
you have a foot on the
floor controlling something.
So what he was thinking
here, his hypothesis
in this experiment, was, why
not use this part of your body
that goes unused to do xy,
pointing on the screen.
Then, you have two hands free.
It's actually kind of
a brilliant hypothesis.
Even today, most
of our work, we're
trying so hard to input all
this stuff into a computer.
50% of our limbs don't
get used for that at all.
This is fine if Wendy
wants to go quit Google
and start up on extra
limb interface design.
You're welcome to do it
because this is an old idea.
But he was on the right track.
He was thinking about how do
people interact with machines.
Eventually, he developed
the model that we know,
this direction.
But even in 1970, 1971,
if he had shown this to us
and we were alive then,
not from time travel,
but we were alive then and
said this is the future,
we'd be like, what
are you talking about?
This is like a box on a string.
The idea is expressing a whole
bunch of assumptions that are
foreign and it will seem weird.
The last piece of advice
here, to drive this home.
I know a lot of this is
history and my promise to you
was to apply history to today.
So what this means
is, all of you
are in meetings when
you're working on products,
you're trying to
solve something,
you're building something, where
you're discussing alternatives.
There's proposal
a, proposal b, c.
And maybe you have
some criteria you're
using to vet them, like
user scenarios or the goals
for your project, whatever.
So you look at idea
a in this discussion
and you say, oh, it's
good in these ways.
Well, that's a good idea.
We'll put it in
the good idea pile.
Then, you go to
idea b and you're
like, oh, we can
see already it's
going to have these issues.
That's going to go
in the bad pile.
And you go through c and d.
Every now and then, you're
going to have an idea that's
proposed that you look at
it in these discussions
and you go, that's,
that's really weird.
And you turn to the person
who proposed it, you're like,
can you explain this?
And they'll probably go,
yeah that's a weird one.
I feel like there's something
really to it that's good,
but I haven't
figured it out yet.
And the natural thing that
we do, since we're efficiency
minded, we have
project deadlines,
we take the weird ideas
and we throw them away
with all the bad ideas.
That's a mistake.
The advice to you is to
keep weird ideas around.
A weird idea means
you don't understand
enough about the
problem or about
the potential of the
idea to evaluate it.
You can't judge it.
And of course, if
you're on a deadline,
you shouldn't ship this
idea you can't evaluate.
But it also means there's
probably potential in it
and if you study it more,
you pay attention to it,
you come back to
it a week later,
two weeks later, your point of
view is going to be different.
You're going to ask
different questions of it.
And you might find something
that leads to a discovery.
Much of the history
of inventors, people
who get credited with
inventing and discovering,
a lot of what--
I shouldn't say a lot
because this is not
a guaranteed method, but there
are no guaranteed methods
in the sort of work.
But many of their
breakthroughs occurred
because of things that
were weird to them,
they kept around, and
kept experimenting on
until they found its value.
And the canonical example of
the story that's most well-known
is the Post-it Note.
The Post-it Note story.
The cliche version is someone
had weak glue, accidentally
discovered weak glue, and that's
how we got the Post-it Note.
But that's a
shallow, empty story.
The true part of the story,
which ties all this together,
yes it's true.
An engineer, at 3M,
was working on trying
to make a strong glue.
And by accident,
he made a weak one.
But he didn't throw it away.
He looked at it and was
like, this is weird.
And he put it aside.
Then, the next day
or a week later, he's
like, what can I do with this?
It can't solve the
intended problem,
but maybe it's good
for something else.
And he kept it around
for years, continually
trying-- let me try it here.
Let me try it there.
He'd go to his
coworkers, go, hey,
I had this stuff--
he didn't tell them
what it was designed for.
He just said, hey,
I got this stuff.
What would you do with it?
Sort of like an improv question.
And he did all sorts
of experiments.
Eventually, one of his coworkers
looked at that and said,
you know what?
Maybe I can use this.
Because he had a problem.
He sang in a choir and he wanted
to put notation on the choir
sheets, the music sheets.
So he said with that soft
glue, that weak glue,
I could possibly
put something on it
that I can easily take off.
That's the breakthrough moment.
What's often not said.
It took years now of refining
that product and convincing
people of its value
for the Post-it
Note to become the product
that we know today.
So in summation, any
story that you know of,
any legendary creation--
in the tech sector,
maybe you think
the iPhone is one of the
greatest things ever made.
Maybe you think PageRank
is a breakthrough
in the history of technology.
Whatever thing you
think of as perfect,
being this masterpiece, they
all have a history where
they started as experiments.
And if you want to be someone
who makes masterpieces or makes
great things, you
want to understand
what that experimental
part of the process
was like because
that's what you're
going to have to emulate in
projects that you are working
on and making something today.
Now, my last lesson for you--
purely about creative
thinking and how
to develop that
skill in yourself--
is that our minds are
naturally creative.
It is wired into us, it's
part of our brain function.
Anyone who is not in prison,
not in a psych ward, functions
in a decent way, can
get to work and home,
has a brain that is
functioning, and creativity
is part of that brain function.
And the best way to
illustrate this to you
is a common scenario that occurs
to us in everyday life, which
is losing your keys.
So imagine tomorrow,
you wake up,
you're getting ready for work--
actually, let's say Monday,
unless some of you are
working on Saturday.
Monday you wake up, you're
going to go to work.
You do your normal
routine and you
do your pre-airlock check of
like wallet, purse, phone,
keys.
And you reach for your keys
and the keys are not there.
You go, OK.
And your brain automatically
goes into first level mode.
Well, where are my keys?
Oh, normally when I come
home, I put them in the basket
by the front door.
OK.
So you go there,
look at the basket.
And if they're not
there, you go, hmm.
Brain goes to level two,
like fault tolerance,
error checking.
Maybe the keys fell
behind the basket,
so you look behind the basket.
Not there.
Now your brain automatically
goes to level three.
Creativity starts to
ensue without any ideation
methods, any
brainstorming techniques.
All of a sudden,
you start looking
in your closet of
clothes that you have not
worn in like a month.
You just do it.
You know it's a little
weird, but it could be.
Somehow they could be there.
When that doesn't work,
you go to the next level.
You probably check
your pants again,
somehow assuming that in the
time that you've been looking,
they have rematerialized
where they should have been.
Then, you go to level four.
Maybe someone broke into
my house and stole them.
But that doesn't make any sense,
of course, because they would
have stolen other stuff, too.
No.
Maybe your cat took--
your brain automatically
goes to these places.
Biologically.
You can't prevent it.
The explanation is
this is the asset
that we have as a species.
We're not the strongest species,
we're not the fastest species.
But our brains are good at
solving problems and inventing
experiments and hypotheses
to try to solve problems.
This situation is
an unpleasant one,
so we're motivated by
a certain kind of fear.
Our brains kick in in a way,
even though losing your keys
is not the end of the world,
it does feel that way.
Your amygdala, the
fight-or-flight response part
of your brain is triggered
in these moments.
And it's not
filtering out anymore.
That's why these
ideas can bubble up
from your subconscious and
you're willing to try them.
Normally, in everyday life,
in ordinary situations,
in work situations,
we have lots and lots
of filters we are
automatically placing on what
our subconscious can do.
In workplaces, it's
often just simply
about wanting to sound smart.
If you have a filter,
you always want
to sound smart in
conversations or you
want to impress your boss
enough to get promoted.
You're going to have a filter
on things that come out
of your mind or come
out of your brain
because you're
trying to be perfect.
But as we've talked
about already,
you have to be willing
to say weird things
and experiment to find
the right way to go.
So there is a mismatch here.
Natural brain function allows
these things to happen,
but there's all these
things and inhibitors
we put on top of
it that prevent it.
To sum this up in a neat little
phrase, when we are suitably
motivated by a hard
problem, creativity ensues.
It just happens.
On its own.
The two things that are
important, suitably motivated,
hard problem.
If you're suitably motivated
to solve an easy problem,
the creativity stuff
doesn't have to kick in.
Losing your keys and if it's
the first place you look, done.
Our brains are lazy.
Why invent all these
weird scenarios?
Suitably motivated
by a hard problem.
Now, to wrap up, I
have three pieces
of specific advice
about creative thinking.
This will be the last
set of points that I make
and then I'll open the
floor for questions.
So number one is
just a summation
of what we talked about before.
Everything I showed you,
Eiffel's work, Doug Engelbart,
da Vinci, when you look at
it from a broad perspective,
what were they all doing?
They were all working.
They had notions for things.
da Vinci was inspired
by the passage he read.
There was an idea there.
But he got to work,
he said I want
to express [INAUDIBLE] I'm
going to try this thing out.
The two young engineers
had an idea, a concept.
They didn't just let it sit as
a concept, they got to work.
They made a sketch,
they made a prototype.
Creativity is best thought of
in the smaller form of the word.
Create.
It's a verb, it's
something that you do.
In the process of
making things, that's
where creativity
can be expressed.
It's not some abstract
thing, some abstract skill
you develop on its own.
It has to be done through
the process of work.
Second, false constraints.
So what I said to
you just a minute
ago about keys
and the inhibitors
that we put upon our brain,
our natural creative brain
function.
There are false constraints
that we put upon our thinking.
And there's a stupid
puzzle that I'm
going to share with you that
you probably have seen before.
How many of you have
seen this puzzle before?
A couple of you.
How many of you heard the
phrase, think outside the box?
How many of you hate the
Think out-- I want all
of you to say it with me.
One, two, three.
AUDIENCE: Think outside the box.
SCOTT BERKUN: OK.
That was not as good
as the first time.
Our cult is falling apart here.
I feel very bad.
AUDIENCE: You said,
say it with me.
SCOTT BERKUN: I screwed it up.
I totally screwed it up.
My fault. I'd make
you do it again,
but I'd rather get
to Q&A. But this
is the source of that saying,
think outside the box.
And the puzzle--
for those of you
who want to solve
it for yourself,
cover your ears and your
eyes for 20 seconds.
No one cares, good.
This puzzle, you're supposed
to connect all the dots
using only straight lines.
And so the solution
of the puzzle
involves you having to
go outside of the box.
And it's a stupid puzzle.
It's not really that important.
The implication here,
though, is good.
It's about false constraints.
The whole notion here
is that no one told you
in solving the problem that you
couldn't work outside the box.
We presume it.
To live in society, we
presume lots of constraints.
When you came in this
room, none of you
sat down up here, next to me.
None of you were standing up in
the middle of my presentation.
There's all these
conventions and constraints
that we naturally
apply to situations.
That's how society
and civilization work.
But we're talking
about creativity here.
The exercise here
that you're trying--
the message they're trying to
get across in this puzzle is
if you work through a list of
all the constraints you think
are true--
let's say you come up
with seven of them--
and it turns out one of
those constraints is false,
that's a window of
possibilities now that opens up.
And that's where ideas are.
It's not this generative
thing, it's actually reductive.
Oh, if I don't have to
worry about budget for this,
OK, now--
If I don't have to worry
about schedule for this
or I have an extra
week, I assumed
this had to be done Friday.
Oh, it's Monday?
Possibilities open up.
So it's a logical exercise.
Any time you're
stuck on a problem,
make a list of the constraints
that you are assuming are true.
Show it to a coworker,
show it to your boss.
They'll go, really?
That's not the goal.
The goal-- you go, ah.
Now, the window of
possibilities opens up.
For fun, there are many other
possible solutions for this.
Infinite in fact.
You could do it in three
lines if you go really
outside the box.
You can do it in one
line, if it's a fat line.
No one told you the
size of the line.
You could do it
in one line if it
goes all the way around the
world and goes back around.
The more absurd you're
willing to get, the more silly
you're willing to get, the more
solutions you can come up with.
But there should be an infinite
number of solutions to this.
So an exercise for you
could be see if you
can come up with more of them.
Then, my last note for
you is about self-respect.
So I told you all
that your brains are
wired by design to be creative.
That stuff is in you.
Society, and as we get older,
and we try to get good grades,
and try to get good jobs,
and good performance
reviews, constraints.
We pile constraints
on and we forget
that natural part of ourselves.
So the best single habit
to learn and practice
is to have a place for
yourself where your ideas can
go that no one will see.
And the most obvious
way to do this
is a journal, some
kind of journal.
A book, it could
be a Google Doc.
It could be anything
where you can
put stuff that's in
your brain, you're like,
that's an interesting idea,
and you can put it down
and no one else is
going to see it.
You are training
your subconscious
to start talking to you again.
And you're going to listen more
carefully now because there's
a place for it to go.
Even more importantly,
our memories are terrible.
We have terrible memories.
Once you put something in the
world, there's some chance--
even if it's a small chance--
that you can come back
to it and go, oh, right.
I can use this in
my next project.
But if it just goes through
your mind and out your brain,
you'll never see it again.
So most artists,
scientists, researchers
keep some kind of journal.
Even people who work
on curing cancer.
They have lab notes.
They put down their observations
and thoughts habitually
so that they can come back
later and go, oh, right.
I forgot about this,
and I thought about this
four days ago.
Put these two pieces
together, boom.
I got something new.
So keeping a journal.
There's an element
of courage to this.
Those two young engineers
had to have the courage
to pitch their
boss and the idea.
Even if you're creative
and you keep a journal
and you develop
your ideas, there's
some element of courage
required because you
are working into the unknown.
If you're pitching
something that's
been done before that you
know is going to work,
there's not much risk there.
We're talking about progress.
We're talking about
good ideas, we're
talking about bigger ideas.
There's going to be risk there.
You're going to be
going into the unknown.
And part of what makes a
good team or a good boss
are people who make you
feel comfortable offering up
things that might not work.
There's some room and
margin for saying things
that are weird or unexpected.
Just like Eiffel
offered his team,
hey, I don't fully
get what you're doing,
but I want you to
keep going and see
if you can develop it further.
And with that, I will end
with some sparkle razzle
dazzle of the book cover.
The book is out now.
The audio book released today.
It's gotten great reviews.
It's got some famous
other creative people
who said good things about it.
And with the rest
of our time, I'm
happy to answer any
questions that you have.
Thank you for listening.
Thanks.
[APPLAUSE]
SCOTT BERKUN: I'm also happy
to be your Snopes for history
of inventions.
It's one of my
hobbies, the history
of inventions of many,
many famous things
that you may know the story
of that you want to know
did that really happen?
Like Newton and the apple
or Alexander Graham Bell.
If you have any of those
legends, you're like,
is that really true?
I'm happy to be your
invention Snopes.
AUDIENCE: Do you plan
a book about those?
SCOTT BERKUN: I'm sorry?
AUDIENCE: Do you plan
a book about those?
SCOTT BERKUN: A
book about those?
I wrote one.
"The Myths of Innovation"
is, in part, that book.
The book isn't anchored
strictly on that.
It's similar to the
lecture I just gave you
about these stories
we think we know,
but trying to use those
stories to apply in real life.
Making decisions
and building stuff.
Yes, sir?
Oh, I'm sorry.
There was a process.
I broke the process.
Yes, sir?
AUDIENCE: All right.
Is this on?
OK.
So if all ideas are
formed from other ideas,
clearly there's value
in exposing yourself
to as many ideas as possible.
I find personally even in my
software engineering work,
I use ideas from TV shows
I watch, video games I
play, all sorts of things.
So what are some things
that you would recommend
doing in your free
time to expose yourself
to as many ideas as possible?
SCOTT BERKUN: That's
a great question.
I think that the one
thing I would say,
you're already well
ahead of the curve.
You've already
realized that this is--
you see the potential in
experiencing other things just
coincidentally.
Like, oh, I can take
this and use it here.
And a lot of the
history of breakthroughs
are these sorts of stories
of a pattern or a method
that's well-known in one
field, being used in another.
The thing I might
encourage you to do
is to pick fields or subjects
you know nothing about.
Because when you go to
a field or a subject
you know nothing about,
you don't have any pressure
of sounding stupid.
So a lot of people who want
to be more inventive and they
work in the tech
sector, they try
to find another tech
sector event that's
more about invention.
And I'm like, no.
Go to an event that's about
a different field, preferably
one where they are inventing
things, but not technological.
And you will hear things
and observe things
that will make you curious.
And that curiosity,
you'll ask questions.
And then asking those
questions you'll
say, well, when I'm
building something,
this is how we do it.
How do you do this?
And those kinds of
conversations, now,
where you're comparing
across fields--
I guess what I'm
trying to say is,
there's probably someone
just like you in the plumbing
industry or the-- you
mentioned games or like the--
someone who makes board
games for a living or someone
who's like a medical engineer.
The closer you
can get to someone
who is a parallel to you
but has the completely
different background, those
kinds of conversations
are the powerful ones.
It's hard to find
those connections
because you have to reach out
across your comfort level.
But again, it's about
going into the unknown.
Next question?
AUDIENCE: So the computers
that we're using today
are based on technology that was
invented in the 20th century.
But in the 19th century, we
had Boole, who did the math,
and Babbage made the the engine.
What were those based on?
What was previous
technology that
was basically the forerunner
of those computers?
SCOTT BERKUN: Sure.
So that's a good question.
I don't know about Boole.
Boole was a mathematician
so he would probably
say there was mathematical
theories and hypotheses he
was following.
Babbage, I'm sure was
influenced by clock making.
For sure.
At that time, the most
sophisticated engineering
for mechanical gear
work were clock makers.
And there's a long history and
tradition of that design work
and engineering work.
I have to believe that
when he started his work,
he looked at clocks first.
And the gearing, I
mean, just the fact
of how do you make intricate
gearing and that kind
of sophistication?
Where would you look if you
were alive at that time?
It had to be clockwork.
For sure.
Another question?
AUDIENCE: Well, I was
hoping to have a little bit
more time to think about it.
SCOTT BERKUN: OK.
Is there an interstitial
question someone
can ask to save your coworker?
You have a question.
AUDIENCE: So about
creativity, is it
something that you can force?
Or are you saying maybe
to carve out time daily
to be creative, or
have ideas, or journal?
SCOTT BERKUN: I think
that the answer is both.
It's an unfair answer.
You can force it.
The key example is a
good example of that.
If you're really desperate,
you're going to be--
again, without even
thinking about it,
without trying to summon your
creative gods or anything,
those ideas just start
going through your mind.
So there is something to be
said for putting yourself
in situations that
will test you.
But the habits of it,
the habits of creation,
are something that you
really need to do every day.
That's what a journal is for.
I mean, to drive the
journal example--
to tie his question
to the journal thing
I was trying to say.
If I had this habit for myself
of I think of some notion
and I put it down.
I think of some notion
And I come back a week later
and I look at that notion
and I go, ah, and
I expand it out.
My own confidence in my
ability to come up with ideas
and to talk to my
own subconscious
improves and improves over time.
So that's like a muscle.
It's like practicing
anything else.
But there are some
situations where
you're going get-- some people
feel most creative when they're
at a deadline or when they
are working on a high stress
project, for some people.
There's no universal
answer to these things,
of course, because
we're all different.
And that's part of why
I hate all these recipe
books, the seven killer
steps, the six secret silver
bullets, because
the goal here is
for you to apply
your unique worldview
and experiences to a problem.
That's what you're trying
to be when you're creative.
So sort of like the
joke where I made
you all say at the same time
all ideas come from other ideas.
There can't be any
universal way to do this.
Part of what you
have to do is to be
more self aware of your
own habits and tendencies.
And a lot of people are
really afraid of journaling
because they're afraid of what
thing they will put in there.
But if you're afraid
of your own ideas then
you probably need
to seek therapy.
No, therapy's a good thing.
It's not a pejorative.
But if really that's
the inhibitor,
it's got nothing to do with
the world or your brain.
It's your own psychology
and your fear of what
your brain may come up with.
You can't be afraid
of that any more.
That's why journaling
helps so much.
You get comfortable and
familiar with the weird things
your subconscious
tends to suggest.
Are you ready for
your question now?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, I think so.
So my question is
at the other end
of the spectrum, where you
constantly think of, oh, maybe
I can do this.
And well, before you're about
to do that you're like, oh, what
about this other idea.
SCOTT BERKUN: Ah, OK.
AUDIENCE: And you have this
infinite loop about new ideas.
Any suggestion for that?
SCOTT BERKUN: I
have a suggestion,
but it's similar to--
let's take this example and
put it into everyday terms.
Let's say I was single and
I go on a first date and I
kind of like that person.
Then, I go on another date.
I kind of like that person.
And I never-- what
would you say?
I never?
AUDIENCE: Commit.
SCOTT BERKUN: Commit.
Never commit.
If you never commit
to something,
that means that you maybe don't
really want to do this thing.
That all those ideas
are good, but maybe you
find it more fun to just play
with the idea in your mind.
For a lot of
people, that's true.
Because as I said,
creativity is work.
Once you say, I want
to write a novel,
I want to start a company.
Hey, it's an epiphany,
it feels great.
Over dinner and wine
with your friends,
I'm going to start a company.
They go, yeah.
Then, the next day, you're
like, oh, I got to call people,
I got to write
documents, I got to--
this doesn't feel
so creative anymore.
This feels like work.
Maybe I'm doing it wrong.
Go to dinner with
your friends again.
Hey, I'm going to make a movie.
And you go through the
same loop of confusing
the fun of coming up with
the idea with the reality
of the work of actually
putting that idea in the world.
So I would say to you
that it doesn't matter.
All of the ideas
you come up with
are probably good, good enough
to put a weekend of time
into them.
But until you put
that commitment in,
you're never going to learn
enough about yourself.
And your own true
interests, they'll
just keep going
along the surface.
Which could be
fine, but you have
to realize that
that's really what
you like to do rather
than being someone
who's committed to an idea to
build it, to build something.
Question?
All right.
AUDIENCE: So this question is
stemming from my discussions
with a friend about creativity.
So personally, in
my free time, I
like listening to podcasts
about various things.
I don't like listening
to music that much.
For example, on
my way to work, I
listen to audio books and stuff.
And according to my
friend, keeping my brain
this occupied, even
in my free time,
it may be destroying
my creativity.
So do you think that
has any validity?
Or--
SCOTT BERKUN: That
should be the podcast.
Creativity destroyer.
Listen to this, you will
never have an idea again.
Yes and no.
Everybody's different.
And the way people
relax and what
makes them feel
comfortable is different.
So there's no universal answer.
I can say though, and there
is neuroscience and cognitive
psychology behind this, why
you get ideas in the shower.
Who here has gotten
an idea in the shower?
Who here showers?
Good.
All right.
Excellent.
What goes on there
is, the reason why
it's become like
a sacred place is
that it's one of the few places
where there's no screens,
there's no music by default,
your body is relaxed,
it's comfortable, and
your higher brain--
the logical part of
your brain-- is quieter.
And there's no input.
So your subconscious, which
is where all the associations
between things the source of
our ideas it's easier for ideas
to bubble up.
So as long as there's some
time regularly for you
where that's true--
and it could be when
you go for a walk,
it could be when
you're running, it
could be when you're at the gym.
As long as there's
some state of mind
that you reach where your
higher brain is quiet,
that's when it could happen.
And for some people listening
to podcasts and stuff.
I listen to the
radio all the time,
I listen to podcasts all
the time, even at the gym.
Sometimes I'm tuned in
and sometimes it's on
and my brain is somewhere else.
So just the fact that that
input is there doesn't mean it
doesn't necessarily define
what's going on in your brain.
But there's lots of
evidence for this.
Often, it's physical
activity where
our higher brains are more
quiet and the subconscious
can bubble up.
So for some people it's
running, or going for a walk,
going for a hike.
So you should think
about what habit you have
where your higher brain
is idle and you're not
problem solving but there's some
other passive thing that you're
doing that works for you.
And you'll have to
experiment to find it.
We have time for maybe
one or two more questions.
Yes, sir?
AUDIENCE: So these days
when we have a problem
or are trying to solve
something, we frequently
go search the web or go to
YouTube, how to do this,
how to do that.
That could be a
little bit similar
to what that [INAUDIBLE]
before me asked.
Now, what's the right
thing to do here?
Now, if you have a problem
and you look it up,
you'll solve the
problem quickly.
But then, you blocked
yourself from finding
a solution yourself.
But on the other hand, you
expose yourself to other ideas.
This is good, as you said.
If you expose yourself
to other ideas,
you will come up with new ideas.
But then, if you don't try
to come up with ideas--
you see the contradiction there?
SCOTT BERKUN: I do.
I guess it's usually
not a problem
because if you were
to say, decide,
that you wanted to
start a company, well
you'd Google, how do
I start a company?
And you'd find a list of things
that you now have to go and do,
like I said before.
Once you start going
and do those things,
you may realize or recognize
that there's a better way
to do them, will be frustrated
with one of those steps,
you'll seek out other ones.
But most of the things
you're likely to look up
as ways to solve the problem
are going to be very abstract.
Like if you were to do a Google
search for how to write a book.
It's going to give you some
basic construction of it,
but it's not going to
tell you whether to write
a novel or a thriller
or a Victorian drama.
There's always going
to be a lot of space
that you need to
fill out yourself.
And so I guess what
I would say is--
it's a very practical answer--
is do the things that actually
help you produce.
If you produce stuff
and you're like,
my solutions and the things I
create are really boring to me,
then maybe say for
the next project,
I'm not going to
research anything.
And experiment that way.
Every project is going to be
different, especially if you're
trying to do ambitious work.
Every project is
going to be different
and it's going to demand
different things of you,
it's going to require different
techniques or skills to try.
So there's no universal
answer, unfortunately.
And that is the case for
a lot of these questions.
A common question I get asked
is how do I know when I'm done?
How do I know when I'm done?
And I'm like, have you
ever consumed something
like a movie or software product
or a book and you're like,
this is terrible.
Yet you paid money for it
and it exists in the world.
Lots of finished stuff, many
people think isn't very good.
Is not done.
I'm sure you have arguments
with your coworkers.
They're like, we need
to ship this today.
And you're like, no
this is terrible.
It's got all these
bugs and problems.
It's inherently debatable,
when is it done.
Inherently debatable.
And the way you solve
those discussions
is with a group of
people, some consensus
on what the criteria is for
actually shipping something.
And you do that with yourself.
Is this essay good
enough to publish?
I don't know.
Is this tweet good
enough to tweet?
I don't know.
Some people spend
time reviewing them
and they put them in
their drafts folder.
Other people, you can tell,
just go blah blah blah,
and push the button.
Right?
So is one right, is one wrong?
Some of those people who just
don't really think about it
much have a lot of followers.
Some people who
are very precious
and care a lot about high
quality don't have many.
Popularity is unfair and
not based on a set criteria
that we all agree on.
And that's part of the
world you enter when
you're doing creative work.
Eiffel Tower, lots of
people at the time hated it.
Were they right,
were they wrong?
Depends on your point
of view and perspective.
And the more creative
the work you're doing,
the more subjective the
ways to evaluate it will be.
So one more?
Yes, sir.
That's OK.
AUDIENCE: So in
education, there's
been a big push
towards preparing
kids for the future, whatever
the jobs of the future are.
And so my own kids, I see them
being pushed in science, math,
computer programming.
You mentioned history
at the beginning.
Are there things you
would like to see
done differently in education
in light of [INAUDIBLE]??
SCOTT BERKUN: Yes, yes.
I think that every
student, everywhere,
should get five copies
of this book and five
for each of their parents, and
that would solve everything.
The creativity answer,
and there's a lot of--
I'm not an expert on this
and I'm not particularly
a fan of Montessori
schools, but the notion
that they have of
self-directed things
seems like the right path to me.
That part of, in
this conversation,
how do you decide, how do you--
it's self-oriented.
That there is less and
less room for that,
it seems like, in most
curriculums and the assumptions
we have about what
people should learn.
And so programming
could be that,
if the goal wasn't simply
to memorize how to code,
but the goal was to learn
how to make your own stuff.
That the goal is to,
every quarter, every week,
you've built something.
And you had your criteria
for it and you evaluate it
and you decide for
yourself what is good.
That kind of process, that's
open-ended is central to this.
And the more you focus
on grades and that--
there's no way to grade
these open-ended projects.
So there's a conflict between
what parents and the school
system often emphasizes--
grades and tests--
versus this psychology and
self-awareness and ability
to choose for your
own self what's
worth making, what's good,
that work against each other.
So some protection
of that, I think,
is the thing I would
think about first.
SPEAKER: Thank you
very much, Scott.
SCOTT BERKUN: Thanks, guys.
Thanks for listening.
[APPLAUSE]